definitely do not get sucked into the
mindset that these things are inherently
top-heavy or frontend costly or anything
is absolutely not true
it was possible to do it much more
efficiently than a lot of people told us
was the case when we kind of surveyed
the landscape of what was out there in
this particular sector even of IT stuff
and we dug around a little to sort of
investigate what kind of costs labor
what goes into this
we were pretty stunned to find out what
people were spending on the front end to
engineer these things put them up we had
a really hard time figuring out what
people were spending all that money on
to create we think very bad products
what is possible for a young person with
an idea in terms of executing it today
even more than five years ago certainly
more than ten years ago
in terms of the speed with which you can
engineer things the software that's
available in an open-source way for you
to construct these things suffice to say
I think if people knew what it what it
cost us to set Crowdrise up they'd be
staggered I think it was like fractional
compared to some of the other big-name
things that you've heard about